I tried honey pass before I don't like
them you know what I'm saying but enough
liquor you know you kill me yeah he's on
my Bluetooth
I ain't got no Bluetooth I call
everything Bluetooth though because I
know what that is have you ever had sex
on mushrooms yes yeah
yeah what what's your guys's review it's
fun it's nice
it's fun I don't really like mushrooms
though
he had a mushroom face yeah
one you had a fan no I just really this
is this my thing you know what I'm
saying I'd rather eat shrooms and do a
lot of other [__]
you know
crazy dog picture being sober around
everybody else's room mushrooms
mushrooms like them [__] were mad at
me at Molly and that was cool no I mean
it was just like on the relaxing tip
like focusing he looked like the bed of
get out of me
you ever have a therapeutic experience
on mushrooms no no [__] I had you
didn't eat a bad trip I had a bad trip
in the house of mushrooms
I thought all right so the first time so
like right when it was getting real
popular you feel me so I had
[__] like I was taking them in
micro doses saying like yeah damn it was
having essentially the same effect like
I feel like a perk I have with me like
on the focus and said you see what I'm
saying yeah for sure have you focused am
I here I'm like all right I've been my
girl does I'm like I'm gonna take
yeah I [__] with them one by one though
but like I'm a grab a bunch
oh what I thought was not a bunch but
maybe more than what the [__] I'm
supposed to have and I'm like I'm gonna
play the game you feel me yeah so I took
him like on some like an end [__] on the
game type [__] boy I'm gonna eat some
right now and I ate some I ate the
[__] look the little chunk I took and
I'm sitting there and I get through one
match we're playing uh Call of Duty then
I get through another match and I'm
feeling [__] kick in but they had an
oil okay let me just kick it in [__] by
the time we got to the third match them
[__] was on me
I'll be right back I ain't come back for
like three hours [__] I took 17 showers
[__]
I I switched my pajamas three four times
and then I got all the sheets off the
bed [__] yeah [__] I was
standing in it so like from my bathroom
17 showers in three hours what did you
take to make you do that mushrooms I
used to think I could like me it was
real it was penis envy Evie
it wasn't no chocolate it was the actual
mushrooms bro I'm watching [__] I'm
watching Hellboy
from the shower because I can see my TV
from like if I can open the door I don't
watch it they're gonna be this enemies
hey you don't hey and they got a gay you
penis envy mushrooms you ate them yeah
you gave me much bro the name of the
strangest penis enemies
drugs one for me right yeah yeah
he was a superhero I'm watching him pop
perks and [__] he go play basketball he
got all the Energizer button these type
of [__] in him he just don't give up
right so me I don't do drugs so I tried
like damn I'm gonna be cool today
I tried to do the perk you feel me yeah
in Kentucky when you did that a video
with King Vine and you couldn't find me
I was sleeping with her
that's why he was M.I.A he was over
Percocet yeah I died though like I
thought I died I kept asking why like
why why I feel like this am I dying and
my body was heating up from the inside
out and [__] and I'm like tired of doing
you feel me I can do that okay I see him
do it and then go put up like 18 points
yeah yeah so I thought I could do that
but then my heart stopped
[__] you never told me you popped no
purpose because I was scared for real
and I don't let y'all know when I was
scared
for my life for real [__] this was
where is this in Kentucky Kentucky yeah
I'm wondering where the [__] you was you
really was missing that's funny bro
whole town cause listen why I'm trying
to kill it it may listen cause every
time I every time I be saying something
about oh like having that Dickie suit on
that night you'd be like I remember that
night but I don't remember you at the
video shoot you was in the [__] car
sleep because Ryan gave me some fentanyl
who gave you what Juan provided that I
was super Gremlin and [__]
that wasn't me man I don't know what
he's talking about he didn't drink water
and then I just just no he used to he
used to smoke like like the most the
most I seen him and if you want to call
it the dream face because Skillet like
he smoked a lot of weed we smoked
together a lot you feel me but my baby
used to smoke and
like how I smoke
17 Blunts and then I might look like I'm
blowed at the end of the night [__] by
like the second blunt it'd be like it
look like skin to be the smoked a pound
like
he used to look so high because listen
he's like as [__] he don't even pass his
blunt no you usually look at his [__] he
usually didn't pass his Bunch but I'm
not gonna he passed the blunt too he had
passed me his butt it's 50 bucks you
know you know you've been to the house
it's 50 Blunts and everybody passing me
to blunt and I'm the one that don't
smoke for real of course I'm a little
like I died because you got 50 I'm 19.
yeah I never really smoked for real yeah
I mean you know how's it going we took
you to the block you know yeah you guys
have a pretty interesting uh crib going
on so how many people you think you
passed the blunt tool no I do when I
started my statement up I didn't say I
was smoking a bunch of [__]
that's how I smoke with you I said [__]
you smoke a lot and I used to smoke with
you
we literally was like the only [__]
with that grade of weed around [__] for
a long time [__] three times they they
get they put moon rock in the blood
how I'm supposed to survive oh yeah that
Moon Rock have you [__]
it's like that like the easiest way for
us to explain Guru rock is like it's a
form of Moon Moon Rock but it don't [__]
your blender it's super smooth and it's
always made with like top shelf flour so
it's the [__] a product that our cousin
man he got us he got a certain recipe
that nobody got no nobody ain't gonna
lie shout out
yeah like he got membership cards all
type of [__] like he's been in Detroit
for a long time yeah but we don't take
it out of town and you know it's still
going yeah